alors ils ont des formes bizarres
pourtant sur son désir souvent bien
français de musiques militaires comme
ces buxin la plupart de ces instruments
et d'époque
grâce à une restauration minutieuse d'un
passionné il reprenne vie
[Musique]
c'est non par contre de recherche de
travail au niveau des acquisitions et et
de restauration aussi puisque cantons
ont fait des brocantes ou en chine où on
achète sur des ventes et spécialiser les
instruments qui nous parviennent ne sont
pas forcément tous jouables en état de
fonctionner donc il faut travailler
dessus
les étudier et puis les restaurer un
conformément à leur intégrité
pensé par le conservatoire de versailles
l'exposition présente six instruments de
manière chronologique à travers une
collection de 260 cuivre
l'exposition
une vocation de voyage on commence par
tout ce qui est ethnique et la
présentation pour comprendre un peu dans
quel milieu où on est et puis finalement
après on déambule de manière
chronologique des cuivres de facteurs
français des instruments américains des
pièces historiques et parfois
surprenantes comme ceux didgeridoo
australien il fait partie de la famille
des cuivres des coquillages ils font
partie la famille des cuivres si ils ont
une embouchure mais peut-être que je
devrais pas bientôt venir le voir pour
essayer de le comprendre elle le croire
l'exposition est articulée autour d'un
point d'orgue un concert le samedi 28
janvier à 20 heures
[Musique]